FBI bias still front and center as news
alarms were raised on Capitol Hill
Senate Homeland Security Committee Chair
Ron Johnson says he has learned of an
anti-trump secret society within the
bureau attended by top level employees I
have heard you know from somebody has
talked to our committee that there is a
group of individuals than the FBI that
was hold they were holding secret
off-site meetings is that half a dozen
what's the number again I I can't I
can't really put a number on it right
now but more than just striking page and
but understand Strachan page were very
high level within the FBI I mean Peter
strikes title was FBI deputy assistant
director of the counterintelligence
division
these aren't low-level underlings these
are individuals that had access to the
highest level including the director of
the FBI the revelations first came to
light through newly released text
messages between former Special Counsel
investigators Peter struck and Lisa page
their techs also raised new questions
about Jim Comey's testimony to Congress
about the Clinton investigation John
Ratcliffe says Comey could be called
again to testify about inconsistencies
he said that no decision was made to
charge Hillary Clinton or to not charge
her with mishandling classified
information until after her July 2nd
2016 interview with the FBI the problem
is these texts indicate that page and
struck and Lynch and virtually every
member of the mid year exam team knew
days weeks and in some cases months
before that she wasn't going to be
charged and that's simply inconsistent
with the testimony that he gave under
oath if all the folks working for the
director knew that she wasn't going to
be charged I think the director had to
know meanwhile there are five months
worth of missing messages between struck
and Paige today we're learning how they
may have mysteriously disappeared the
FBI tells Fox News quote a few thousand
cell phones of employees were affected
by a technical glitch between December
2016 and May 2017 which prevented
messages to be stored or uploaded to the
Bureau
archive system Kimberly I want to start
with you on these missing text messages
the FBI's primary job is I think data
collection and evidence collection and
they have multiple backup layers triple
backup quadruple backup and those
prevent against earthquakes and 9/11
attacks and fires it's to blame it on a
glitch they've got to be recoverable I
think they might just be buying time
what do you think there's plenty of
cases that I prosecuted where people
have tried to destroy evidence I always
get it you have to know who to go to but
the FBI so they should be able to pull
it together can you imagine if every
investigation they did was thwarted by
people who tried to obstruct justice and
delete emails and do things like of this
nature but when you look back at the
Hillary Clinton investigation look how
that was handled and the bleach bed and
the destruction of evidence etc etc this
is very disconcerting but I do want to
say that obviously the majority of FBI
agents and men and women that work there
they're outstanding and committed and
dedicated and fantastic and we really
owe them so much because they they make
hardly any money they work incredibly
long hours to keep us safe domestically
so when you see something like this I'm
glad that the people who have been like
a couple of bad apples or being you know
rooted out because you want always a
fair and impartial investigation and
what I'm concerned about now is that why
are these missing I do believe they'll
be able to recover any kind of deleted
files there's tremendous technology and
forensic recovery to do just this for
people obviously people don't want to
get caught they don't want to leave them
stuff like that out there so they tried
to delete it and remove it so it cannot
be used against them however if the FBI
can't do this and pull it together and
get it we had a problem big problem
Kimberly brought up the Hillary Clinton
situation and you're looking right at me
yes Murray we're going to direct this
question to you so Comey has some
inconsistencies he said under oath that
he never decided to charge Hillary
Clinton before he interviewed her he was
going to wait till after the interview
now we have the exoneration letter and
we have the text between Strock and
Paige that say that Lynch the Department
of Justice chief knew that the fix was
in on him
beforehand so if Comey comes back do you
think Kobe's in trouble
I don't I actually don't I think Jim
Comey took a lot of notes I think he
wrote everything down and nothing we've
heard proves that he said anything
incorrect in testimony and fine bring
him back but look I think how do you
explain the exoneration I think well
there are a number of good explanations
including the fact that he may have also
written in a letter that wasn't
exonerating her Oh have we seen that one
well people who are trying to go after
Jim Comey haven't leave maybe they miss
that letter so there's a partisan reason
that hasn't been leaked if you ever
thought of that no I have not well thank
you for bringing it to my attention but
I think here's the thing I agree that
these were bad apples as soon as Bob
Muller learned of these text messages he
fired them from the investigation what I
don't like is extrapolating from these
texts which we don't know the whole
story I think these I think struck and
Lisa page need to answer questions but
extrapolating from these text messages
to then somehow the entire Moeller
investigation not being credible
I'm not saying everyone's making that
leap but some people are and I don't
think that that's fair to the patriotic
FBI agents who are still working on it
okay I see the point but where are the
text messages it's very suspicious Dana
I know you've been a little hesitant to
convict that's more than I have but we
always talk about police officers and if
say if a police officer is a racist guys
a white cop these racist doesn't like
black people and he's out there
patrolling a all-black neighborhood we
always say you know what that's that's
troubling you don't want to have bad
apples bad cops patrolling that kind of
beat right here you have Trump hating
FBI agents policing the Trump
investigation doesn't that show bias and
shouldn't that kind of well what we know
based what Murray just said is that as
soon as Miller finds out takes over the
investigation finds out about them
he fired was the damage already done it
I don't know they they still been in the
FBI they're not firing okay look I get
it I I don't know and truthfully nobody
knows maybe the members on the hill know
but they're not being forthcoming either
they're saying like what we're gonna
like give you a little taste of
we're gonna basically try to destroy the
reputation of the FBI and piece by piece
so that we can defend against these
allegations of collusion which in the
text messages that actually do exist
Peter struck says you know there's no
there there so in some ways the
Republicans should say oh I like that I
don't like that text message and if you
remember you go back to when Comey was
about to well when he announced that he
was not going to prosecute Hillary are
not recommended at the time we had many
people on the Trump campaign supporters
of the Trump campaign saying that they
had sources within the FBI saying that
all throughout the FBI there were so
many agents who were furious at Comey
because they could not stand Hillary
Clinton they could not believe this
happen so it's hard for me to believe
that now all of a sudden that same FBI
is rife with people who actually hate
Trump and they're actually Pro Hillary
and now they're so then just before we
got came down here the Democrats now
have written their own memo okay so now
you have one partisan memo versus
another partisan memo and both are like
I might reveal it I might reveal it but
if I just could president Trump could
reveal them if you wanted to I think
it's a mistake to go down this road if
they release those memos they must
release the underlying applications that
go with them because the FISA warrants
that come forward out of that or that
that produce the wiretaps that get the
information if they don't have anything
to do with that period that you're
talking about then you have a much
bigger problem on your hand so I think
it's better for everybody to just stop
right now and let them all do their jobs
it's the committee do their job let
Muller do their job and then we can have
a calm in the secret society
maybe that's why don't you remember that
though how many people came on Fox News
and they said all these people within
the FBI but but here's the thing there's
different management and field offices
the field officers are the ones who do
the hard work and management for the
most part are separate so one thing has
made clear to me in talk and FBI agents
they're not management because they're
better they're management because they
chose that career path I'm gonna go to
Washington be a manager as opposed to be
in the field office and follow cases
so Andy McCabe wouldn't necessarily be
the second
best FBI agent in the country he just
happens to be the deputy you chose that
path for his career a couple of things
on this on James Comey if the memo is
correct commis got a problem he said in
September 2016 when asked did you make
the decision about hillary clinton to
recommend criminal charges hood to the
classified information before or after
hillary clinton was interviewed he says
only after he said she maybe lied the
interview in a way which he did not lie
in the interview in a way that we could
prove I didn't know what was gonna
happen before that interview so he's
already on the record saying he didn't
make up his mind so he's got to come up
with an answer for that on the on the
problem with Samsung Samsung called
in the middle of the show today on Fox &
Friends because we were talking about
Samsung was there a problem with their
equipment they say we believe that
Samsung devices are not the cause of
this issue we fully we will fully
cooperate with any investigation and
then Fox News learns a few thousand FBI
employees cell phones were affected by a
technical glitch they say we have 35,000
agents about 10 percent were looked at
and they're taking steps now to possibly
recover the text messages so that's an
issue I actually think that the FBI is
grown-up enough and smart enough to
understand we're not saying anything bad
about them we're saying something
questionable about these two in
particular not too thrilled with Bruce
or and his wife on fusion GPS either and
I think we have the right to question
for example if you're in an organization
that's running well and four or five bad
apples do some horrible things it should
not reflect on us we know that well data
made the point that struck when he was
invited to join the Muller team said
that you know he didn't really see a lot
of their there with the collusion case
and he was reticent to join because it
was not it's not gonna help his career
he's like that why would I want to go do
that there's nothing and then a
subsequent text he said said something
about wanting to take care of unfinished
business based off what wasn't resolved
a Hillary Clinton campaign and then a
subsequent text mentioned impeachment so
you're right when you look at that you
don't have the context but there's
another reason for him to join the
Muller team do you think the Muller team
at this point is compromised yes or no
well I think they're certainly
an air of impropriety um in terms of as
it relates to but you know we don't know
all the evidence and facts yet but I
think questions need to be asked and
answered and I think that you know
Attorney General Jeff Sessions is also
aware of everything that's going on and
so and we're gonna have to find out I
mean there's a social lab to get
involved or you know but that's what I
think I mean I think that this is
amazing so we had this whole fight
between President Trump and Jeff
Sessions sessions not fighting very much
about his decision to recuse himself and
then you have the Attorney General
making to sit in making direction to the
FBI about this case regarding these text
messages which should be done by the
deputy it's bizarre to me it just
doesn't seem very many public statements
about it and which is yeah I think
bowlers got to continue to though I
don't think anything here stop smaller
from going forward at all I think that's
me fired struck is actually works is in
his favor but did something happen now
this is a question whether struck when
he talked to Flynn was that
inappropriate that something
inappropriate happened there initially
which then led to what we have now which
is guilty pleas I'm asked to know what
Flynn actually said to set him up with a
question that he knew he would answer we
do know that if text came out and there
were Trump loving FBI agents saying make
America great again we have to prevent
missing I think yeah because I think
they're left to be singing a different
story